wordsmiths we're in it now you and I the
situation has become very serious you
might even say it's a crisis yes crisis
is the word we're going to be looking at
in this video crisis it's a noun it
means a Tipping Point a very dangerous
period or situation but its literal
meaning comes from the verb K in Greek
meaning to judge to choose to decide um
so Kine becomes crit or Chris to choose
choose to
decide in crises for that is the plural
of Crisis crises we must choose what to
do The Balancing Act is no longer
available a situation must go one way or
another a boulder on a Mountaintop a
cherry on a Sunday a meatball on a
carrot they must go one way or another
but they cannot remain in crisis they
cannot remain in this urgent unstable
situation a crisis by its very nature
must resolve for good or for bad what
are some other words that have that crit
or chis word part in it those words that
might mean judgment or choice or
dangerous give it 10 seconds while I
throw on some dangerous music let's
[Music]
go here's what I thought of critical an
adjective meaning very important or
necessary like a critical ingredient in
a recipe a critical ingredient in a
tomato sandwich is a tomato critical can
also mean exercising judgment as in
critical thinking when you use your
judgment on a situation or on a con
Academy reading passage wink hypocrite a
noun meaning a person who pretends to be
good a hypocrite says one thing and then
does the opposite like if I talked a big
game about ocean conservation but then
threw a bunch of trash into the water
when nobody was looking that would make
me a hypocrite I judge others right for
the stuff that I do myself and finally
critic a noun a person who judges stuff
for a living a movie critic a restaurant
critic their jobs are to watch films or
eat at restaurants saying to their
readership or their followers I liked
this movie or I didn't like this
restaurant the work of a Critic is
called criticism
let us not neglect the present crisis
however and use the word crisis in a
sentence Marcus watched the shipping
crisis unfold from his perch in the
lighthouse you can tell it's a crisis
because ships aren't meant to go
Bonk all those ships are getting stuck
on each other but they can't stay like
that forever a crisis is a big problem
and if the ships can't get out of the
canal or wherever that's a crisis for
sure all right let's try another one you
can't get through to Denise when she's
in crisis mode people can have emotional
crises or be in states of high alert
maybe you've heard the phrase midlife
crisis when middle-aged people suddenly
freak out about the way they've spent
their lives I went on a big trip when I
was 25 and I called it my quarter life
crisis Adventure I was anticipating a
crisis and it never came actually
instead I ended up working for KH
Academy which rules I hope you enjoy
watching these videos as much as I enjoy
making them because I'm having a
delightful time you can learn anything
Dave it out